si vous étiez hier au rendez-vous vous
avez sûrement été frappé par le
reportage ramené par françois corner du
liban ce reportage où l'on voyait pour
la première fois un camp d'entraînement
de commandos arménien le porte parole de
ce groupe lié à la salle à l'armé
secrète de libération de l'arménie
tenait des propos particulièrement
violent qui n'engagent bien sûr que ces
extrémistes là et non pas la communauté
arménienne dans ses différentes
expressions l' enquête sur le problème
arménien va ce soir nous entraîner en
turquie maurice werther et françois
granier y ont rencontré des arméniens
qui continuent de vivre en turquie
il y à une tragédie arménienne celle de
1915 ou par milliers les arméniens de
turquie ont été déportés en partie
exterminés il y à la tragédie de nos
jours les arrières petits-fils de cela
déclare qu'il se venge sur les
diplomates turcs partout dans le monde y
compris en france pour les turbos
aujourd'hui la vérité historique c'est
qu'en 1915 la turquie en guerre se
battait sur quatre fronts la population
arménienne de l'est du pays face au
front russe s'était révoltée aussi
fut-elle déportées en masse vers le sud
dans des conditions extrêmement pénibles
froid intense pas de ravitaillement au
milieu de combats ce qui explique le
nombre très élevé de victimes
ce n'était pas une extermination
systématique un génocide
mais un acte de légitime défense 10 les
turcs
il est environ soixante mille arméniens
en turquie la plupart dans la ville
d'istanbul la majorité font commerçants
ou artisans et semble financièrement
forte à l'aise en tout cas ils veulent
publier un passé pénible de latrines
d'air ça peut être certains événements
certaines choses mais de tuer il ya des
longues années
et puis comme la france et l'allemagne
aussi a eu beaucoup de choses pendant
dix carrière il faut oublier
je sais mais ce n'est pas la peine
discute efficace moi je suis très
content si maintenant c'est une histoire
qui est passé les hermines une pure qui
sont une minorité une petite minorité
une minorité distinctes ou assimilés
est-ce que vous vous sentez turc
j'aime beaucoup mon pea en tout cas vous
sentez arménienne structure les deux je
me sens armées hia être quand même temps
à égalité sont très content ici ni
aucune différence entre nous est-ce que
vous avez des ennemis qui ne sont pas
des arméniens oui bien sûr par exemple
je peux montrer une mamie qui étudie les
moyens de ces mamies je travaille avec
lui depuis quatre ans n'ont aucun
problème entre nous tout en chantant
nous se disant parfaitement pur les
arméniens conserve des particularités
des traits distinctifs
on pourrait presque appeler nationaux
ainsi à istanbul il publie un journal
jamanak qui tire à 5000 exemplaires pour
les prendre cinq mille arméniens de la
ville les uns viennent de france de
critiques lettre restée en turquie et
pourtant c'est nous qui avons gardé
conservé la langue et nos traditions nos
églises nos écoles
si les arméniens au moins certains
d'entre eux ont gardé la connaissance
sinon usage de la langue arménienne
ce qui finalement les distingue
indiscutablement des autres cures
musulmans la femme et 19 et quelques
pourcents c'est leur religion chrétienne
orthodoxe de rites grégorien il y à 28
églises arméniennes à istanbul le
dimanche rassemble un bon nombre de
fidèles pour la célébration de la messe
les autorités religieuses bien entendu
sont celles qui condamne le plus
fermement le terrorisme arménien qu'est
ce que vous pensez du terrorisme qui se
réclame l'arrivée fait triste le
patriarche toutes les avec toute
l'église tout les le clergé et tout le
peuple tient bon sens ils sont tous
contre ça on n'apprécie pas et nous
pensons que ça fait un très mauvais
reflets sur le moral est sur la bonne
réputation des arméniens
ce n'est pas une moyenne haute au régis
mais quand vous savez c'est un peuple
dispersé par taux ne pouvons pas
contrôler les autorités de l'église
c'est tout ce qui sent en responsable
position ils ont parlé et ont condamné
ça en fait le possible mais c'est triste
qu'on peut pas contrôler ainsi les
arméniens de turquie fragments d'une
antique nations sont citoyens turcs à
part entière avec un droit revendiqué à
la différence